greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
and today we're going to talk about what
is digital marketing so thanks for
joining us here at simply learn and
let's get started
so today we're going to talk about why
digital marketing is important in
today's world we're also going to talk
about what is digital marketing and
they're the types of digital marketing
channels that are out there then we're
going to talk about the customer
lifecycle in digital marketing so what
does it take to get somebody from point
A to point Z through digital marketing
and so those are the topics we're going
to cover so hope you enjoy yourself
while you're learning and let's get
right to it so let's start talking about
why digital marketing is important so
let's start there on the Y so we're just
a fly on the wall and we're in an office
environment we're looking at two friends
having a conversation about digital
marketing so really if we're listening
in everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digital marketing is become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise so in response hey
over the past few decades digital
marketing has evolved at a rapid pace
these days a lot of people spend most
their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every 60 seconds so
according to social media today I mean
there's a lot of snaps there's a lot of
clicks there's a lot of text there's a
lot of videos watched there's a lot of
pictures being taken there's a lot of
voice-activated activity going on a lot
of tweets email swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
of course I can certainly clarify a few
differences between digital and
traditional and so he goes on to say
what the differences are between
traditional and digital elements look at
that
okay so on traditional marketing we're
talking about print radio billboard
newspaper TV anything that's not on your
mobile or laptop so we know what
traditional marketing reaches limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for X
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you basically
create a thousand Flyers okay you figure
that's going to a thousand people maybe
they'll share it so you're looking about
2,000 people maybe just to be generous
well digital marketing
we're promoting an event we can promote
it to a whole lot of people depending on
the platform so 2000 is nothing when
you're targeting an audience on Facebook
or Google search traditional marketing
non versatile and with digital marketing
is very versatile so again going back to
our flyer print an eight-and-a-half by
11 okay that's it you know with with
digital marketing running display
banners go for 68 by 60 200 by 200 250
by 250 300 by 300 I mean the list goes
on on the types of different display
sizes not to mention text ads not to
mention video or multimedia so the wat
you can do to get your message out there
okay with traditional it's always
delayed communication okay so meaning if
you're trying to get that TV spot there
might not be a spot open until 1:00 in
the morning okay well what does your
marketing there is no hours okay you can
certainly get your point out there and
have people see it instantaneously so
which rich marking there's a lack of
real-time results I mean this seems like
it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant
okay nowadays go in analytics you can
look at real-time reporting okay
we could see real-time results okay
traditional marketing can be very costly
I mean if you're not only doing
postcards and printing postcards but you
have to mail those postcards so there's
postage fees where with digital
marketing it's very very very cost
efficient
I mean meaning you could pick and choose
who you want to target one you want to
target where you want to target what you
want to target and if you're doing
search you can put your bidding in place
you can put your hours in place you can
really control how much you actually
spend so that's amis one of the biggest
advantages to digital marketing not only
do you get real-time results but you
could control cost and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of cost
you're spending based on those real-time
results with traditional marketing it's
difficult to reach a target audience you
know which is your marketing it's easy
to reach a target audience I mean you
know I don't want to bash traditional
marketing too much I mean if you're
gonna put a TV ad in place you know
you're gonna do it on a TV show that
tends to gear more towards your target
audience but that doesn't guarantee
anything here we can simply go to
Facebook or Twitter or LinkedIn and just
pick and choose specifically who we want
to target when we want to target them so
it just becomes a lot easier to reach
each targeted audience on a digital
marketing platform and then with
traditional marketing pour campaign
measurement we're digital you have easy
to measure optimize campaigns and what
we really mean by that is because you
get instant time results because you can
control cost because you can reach your
target audience more easily all those a
result of okay you can measure and
optimize based on what our audience is
seeing and how much they're spending to
see it we can quickly make adjustments
in order to optimize the campaign for
better performance so that's generally
if that means as a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now why digital market has been answered
with all the benefits that it carries
let's talk about the what-ifs digital
marketing so you know that you know you
want to do digital more
so how do we go about that what what is
it exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
Digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is you're really
just using technology to promote your
product or service so we know because of
the benefits in digital marketing you
can promote your campaign on different
platforms ok so all these benefits we
mention about instant real time results
cost efficiency optimizing campaigns you
could do that on surge you could do it
on social via email on mobile apps etc
so that's what we mean by with the help
of digital devices in technology well
these digital devices and Technology
come in the form of search engines and
emails and mobile apps etc so when we
want to go and promote our product or
service using a campaign we have
different options so there are different
types of digital marketing channels that
we could choose from and let's just go
through that list of digital marketing
channels and the first one is what I
consider the king of them all
and that's SEO so SEO stands for search
engine optimization
they're search engine marketing there's
email marketing affiliate marketing
social content mobile and then we can
get into subsets of each of these
digital marketing channels but really
we'll start with SEO because that's the
king and to me that's basically
increasing the quality and quantity of
relevant organic traffic on the search
engines including Google's so depending
on where you're located in the US market
Google
tenth work has a large market share so
you want your pages on your website to
be found and clicked on organically and
so that means if somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but worldwide you search on a daily
basis so if you're ranking for those
relevant keywords you can imagine how
much traffic you can get okay so that's
SEO okay and here's an example so you
type in online shopping well you can see
the first listing here is a paid search
ad I'm going to get to that in a minute
the second organically is Amazon okay so
online shopping
you think maybe Walmart you think maybe
Alibaba or you're thinking probably
Amazon okay so no surprise Amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for Amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as SEM or pay-per-click or
cost per click or PPC or CPC or
sponsored search or Google Ads
I mean there's a lot of different name
synonymous with SEM so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword you don't have to worry
about organic if you're willing to pay
for it you just bid on that keyword and
wallah you have the opportunity to
appear number one in the search results
at the top of the page for that keyword
now when somebody clicks on it you have
to pay Google if it's Google your
advertising on but that's the beauty of
search engine marketing you can bid on
keywords and appear at the top of the
search results for that keyword example
here if we go back to online shopping
well myus.com is bidding on that keyword
online shopping so they're actually
appearing above amazon's or
listing but that's what they want to do
they want to be found for that keyword
so if they're not ranking forward
organically well they're bidding on it
and if somebody happened to clicked on
that listing then myus.com is gonna pay
Google something depending on what the
cost per click is and so that could be
anywhere from one penny to a hundred
dollars
it depends depends on the keyword it
depends on who else is bidding on the
keyword it depends on the location it
depends on the time of day it depends on
quality scores a lot of factors involved
and regarding what you pay however the
benefit of SEM is visibility and getting
traffic to your website for keywords
you're not found for so that's why SEM
such a popular choice for a lot of
companies okay let's talk about digital
marketing and that's a traditional type
of digital marketing channel it's been
around a long time you know we all send
emails on a daily basis and we probably
all receive emails on a daily basis just
as an effective way to capture leads and
get birthed them to customers because
with email you can personalize your
emails and you could send your emails to
a segmented audience okay so if you have
emails from females who at 35 years of
age to 44 that live and say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that sentiment email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call-to-action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out you're
selling a product and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let me know hey you have until
tonight to purchase the product and if
you purchase it you're gonna get 30% off
and you can put the coupon code right in
there with a nice call-to-action and you
can measure how many people click on
that email go to that webpage and
purchase the product using that coupon
code so that's an example of email
marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting merchants to promote your
products and services and you using
usually a third party broker like
Commission Junction or CG comm as an
example to introduce you be the person
selling the product a merchant with the
affiliate so that affiliate could likely
be a merchant him or himself and they
can basically be a good partner of yours
by promising your product or service on
their website so that they can sell in
order to get Commission's so it's all
based on a commission so you basically
are gonna use a third-party affiliate
like CJ get all these affiliates to work
for you
they're gonna promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're gonna pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example of affiliate
marketing at work okay you basically see
a banner basically you can see earn up
to 12% advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so somebody
clicked on that purchase for example or
joined you could pay out that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I would say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
were in 2019
and I remember talking about Facebook
back in 2006 so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform that really drives the type of
content you're gonna promote but we know
social media can be effective because
people use social media I mean Facebook
is one of the more popular platforms and
if you want to get your product or
service out there you could certainly
pay to have an ad on Facebook or you
could just post your content organically
okay that's the beauty of social most of
your social platforms like LinkedIn and
Twitter and Facebook and Pinterest and
Instagram they'll have a paid form of
advertising that you can use to promote
your product or service or you can go
the organic route and you know post
content organically in hopes of driving
traffic back to your website so with
social you do have two options here but
social is interesting because there's a
lot of different social media platforms
out there it really depends on your
product or service okay so an example of
social media marketing especially on
Facebook with Facebook you got mobile
and desktop and you obviously have the
opportunity to close something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing it's a
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
I post or it could be a video where it
could be an infographic or it could be
an image okay there are lots of ways to
create content these days especially in
digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is writing
content for a targeted audience so if
you're trying to target an audience on
say Instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're gonna post on there so
it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example we look at
YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing
so that's content marketing and then
let's talk about mobile marketing so
content marketing again different types
but if we go now to mobile marketing you
can kind of segue from content to mobile
because the only difference here is with
mobile is strictly on mobile phone it's
not desktop so mobile marketing is
really a strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablet and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do a via
email or you could do it via an app okay
so you have different ways of getting
your content out there to people okay so
as an example you can use basically SMS
or instant messaging via mobile devices
to promote your product or service
here's another example of a mobile
marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say Google ad as an example
and running your Google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bit adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to really promote your app
or your product or your service via
mobile marketing okay let's talk about
the customer lifecycle so we know why we
want to do digital marketing we wanted
that we want we know what the digital
marketing channels are because we just
talked about them from SEO to social to
affiliate to mobile to content to SEM
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's where we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
lifecycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling
what we're promoting okay so the
awareness stage is really what product
does your brand offer that's a question
we want to get out there and we want to
answer okay what does a customer need
your product or will excuse me why does
a customer need your product that's a
question we want to answer with digital
marketing okay what solution does your
product provide okay that's an answer to
a question we want to make sure people
understand so these are questions that
we want to be able to answer in the form
of digital marketing whether that be
mobile or content okay so getting our
information out there that answers these
essential questions and if we could do
that then somebody's gonna become aware
of our product or service okay so what
product is our brand offer why does the
customer need it and what solution does
it provide okay those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do I really need this it's gonna help me
in my life okay and who is selling this
I mean who is this brand I mean that's
those are just things like run through
people's mind and to
that with the right messaging the right
channel the right type of asset the
right targeted audience you can quickly
make somebody aware of your brand's
product or service in this stage it's
helped potential customers discover your
brand with the help of these different
marketing channels so when the awareness
stage you know content is key so it's to
me if we have a website we need a blog
because if somebody does come to our
blog from say organic search SEO then we
can write about that product or service
via blog and talk to our customer talk
directly to our targeted audience
through that blog and if we're not
ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on Google for example basically we can
be right at the top of the search
results and so somebody can actually see
it when they do a search because we know
mains of people you search on a daily
basis you could do social media
marketing okay so you can publish that
product or service on Facebook while
you're building your community and you
can these affiliate marketing to help
get the word out by using CJ calm as an
example build up a sales force of people
these publishers that are going to put
your product or service out there so to
me in the awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now I will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display ads mean that if you're on
Google's Display number you can pick and
choose your sites your demographics
keywords topics in audience you can
focus on all those different
demographics to really attract a large
number of people so low priority but
it's probably also good to focus on in
the awareness stage so content marketing
you must create a high quality content
people are searching for without content
it's hard to get found and so to me this
is you
where the guac comes in SCO take that
content get it optimized okay SEM if
we're not ranking organically we can
make sure the top of the paid search
results or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel if we're selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
LinkedIn is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate you know basically
building up a nice network of publishers
to get the word out so these are all
good channels that we can focus in on so
traffic sources may include paid unpaid
social referral display email or direct
so they could come in the awareness
stage from all different types of
channels even though you're focused on
content I mean you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so you know
people are aware of us now the
considering us and that's kind of the
next stage in the process okay so a few
essential questions to address on the
consideration stage
hey what features make your product
valuable to others and how will increase
customer engagement towards my product
so those are answers to questions you
want to ask okay what features make your
product valuable you want to basically
separate yourself from the competition
basically that's what you're trying to
answer okay so if you're promoting your
product or service on paid search and
other people are bidding on the same
keyword how are you gonna stand out and
then how I increase customer engagement
towards my product so any for example if
you're on Facebook okay and you're
trying to get people over to your site
to purchase your product then how you
going to improve that engagement you got
to create something really snazzy or
really it's gonna be attention-grabbing
or something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's gonna separate
your posts from all the other posts
better in somebody's Facebook newsfeed
okay so you really have to work hard to
really convince somebody to get their
consideration towards your product
servus so in this stage your customer
considers your products so help them
understand how your product is valuable
okay to me email works really good here
because if you have a targeted audience
this gives you the opportunity to really
answer this questions in that particular
channel email you can support that with
the promotion and display
I think display is a good option here
too because even though you know people
are trying to become aware you know you
can really hone in and really get them
to take that next step okay with display
you can even do remarketing so if
somebody's been to your site because
they're aware of your product they're
curious you can cookie them and remark
it to them via display so display to me
is a good a good channel to use here
okay so you have email mobile display
you know SEM these are all you know good
channels to use on the consideration
stays especially on search because
somebody's looking for something and
they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so people are aware we're
moving them further along the funnel
with email marketing we have the
opportunity to promote the product by
sending an email directly to our
audience so with this stage plan your
campaigns around welcoming emails
newsletters we can talk about product
descriptions add ratings and reviews and
the email you know we really just want
to encourage people to purchase the
product that's we're trying to sway them
over so email is a good source to allow
us to do that so with mobile marketing
we can promote the products by setting
relevant messages to our target audience
display again retargeting because we can
retarget an audience that has been to
our website already did some research
about our brand or product or service
and now we're going to reach back out to
them to sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
okay we want to opt for a customer
testimonial okay that helps sway people
and add some guest blogging okay we can
have ambassadors blog on our behalf or
we can go out and blog on somebody
else's site okay it's a blogging works
both ways it's ways of showing yourself
and telling people hey we know you're
looking for this product here's why you
want to choose us okay moving on from
the consideration to the purchase stage
so there where of you they're
considering you and now we're on to the
purchase stage so the questions we want
to really make sure we address here are
how are my prices compared to my
competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but that price point and
it may not even be the price it could be
the shipping for example the price could
be good but the shipping cost could be
high so you really want to do some due
diligence and research on what your
competitors are doing credibility that
goes back to the consideration stage and
testimonials you want to make sure you
have reviews and testimonials to really
elevate what you're trying to tell
customers and that that is hey I have a
good brand I have a good product I have
a good service come buy my stuff come
buy my product and service but you
really need to support that claim you
just can't go out and say it and the
supporting that comes in the form of
what other people say and that could be
reviews that could be comments on a
social media platform it could be you
know stars on say Yelp or Google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure you get
people to you know review you or provide
testimony Allah
people are going to do their due
diligence before they purchase
especially if it's on Google my business
or Yelp or TripAdvisor or whatever it is
you're trying to sell they're going to
be able to see those reviews and so do
your due diligence to get the reviews
you know if it is a negative review hey
that's okay you can't please everyone
you're gonna get them that's the world
we live in just make sure you show your
upper hand
and respond even to the negative as well
as the positive reviews that you get
that actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that I made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting in
to purchase a look
hey this brand really cares because
they're really responding to people
they're not ignoring negativity okay
just the small things they can get
people to change their mind
now with the purchase stage according to
e consultancy eighty three percent of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending out an
email means that if the promo is going
to an @midnight send that email out and
tell people they have until midnight and
if they purchased today you'll even
increase it to 20% an email is a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of people through SMS okay social media
reaching people instantaneously and then
you know really with the purchase stage
it gives prospects an offer to help them
make that purchase so you have plenty of
channels to choose from in fact most of
these channels the only one really that
doesn't fit the instantaneous mode is
SEO but you can really focus on
affiliate even though that's a little
priority here you can really you know
coordinate with your publishers who
especially those publishers that have
proven their worth and have sold your
products in the past you get them to
help promote it and incentivize their
audience so let's move on from the
purchase to the purse post purchase
stage so this is after somebody
purchases okay so some essential
questions we want to be able to address
here so what additional product could my
customer buy now that they're my
customer what else could I sell them
what you know without being too pushy
could if they buy a coat whoa a hat work
or a pair of gloves or you know blouse
you know you want to be able
you know push a product under customer
but think about how you can complement
that purchases that purchasers or
customers product and then how to
improve the customer buying experience
so again this goes back to you know what
we just said about reviews get somebody
to offer review and if they don't give
you a full complement of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is with a
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's definitely something you want
to be able to address in the post
purchase stage so let's take a look here
so with post purchasing stage you know
it's me emails at the top of this list
because if somebody purchased is
something you could send a nice
thank-you email because if they purchase
they're giving you their email in return
because you're likely gonna be sending
them the receipt via email so email to
me is a nice channel sending a nice
message even you know social media you
know you can thank your community for
supporting you on this recent campaign
that you ran you know even throw in an
extra five or ten percent on a future
purchase as a thank you and that's
easily done on social media you know you
can even place the blog you know
promoting you know the success of a
product and then offering a promotion
okay so there's a lot of things you
could be doing here on the post
purchasing stage so to me even looking
at content again you could even you know
put a survey together you could even put
a survey together for your affiliates
okay you can even post a poll on
Facebook so it's just working in with
these different channels to get some
feedback about your products and service
so with email mobile you can engage
customers with follow-up emails or
customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way
you know you could say hey look if
you're satisfied let us know give us a
call you can even in the e mobile text
message you can put a link to a serve in
send emails to active subscribers give
rewards for customer feedback so if
somebody does provide feedback yeah I'm
gonna extra 10% off you know you want to
be able to reward loyalty loyalty comes
in the form of a partnership if you're
giving somebody discounts and you have a
good product or service then they're
gonna recognize that they're gonna say
hey look I really like this product and
they're giving me ten percent I'm gonna
go ahead and purchase from these guys
again so give those discounts those
active customers or on the affiliate
network give referral opportunities to
your customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site you know reward them or if
it's an email and you put a board to a
friend get an extra 10% off it doesn't
hurt because you're incentivizing people
to help you sell your product so with
social display and content and use those
banner ads or use that content that you
display on social or the blog you're
gonna write to give customers advice in
order to maximize the value of the
purchase so again you can use these
platforms to also enhance what they
purchased so hey you just purchase this
product thank you very much did you know
you could do this this and this with it
and so that's the idea of a post
purchase stage is to maximize these
channels to be able to answer those
essential questions about what else
could they purchase you know do they
like how do I be get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage the customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale a cross sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage hope you
enjoyed our video today one thank you
for paying attention if you have any
questions please visit us
simply learn calm or visit us on our
YouTube channel there's plenty of videos
about some of these digital marketing
channels we discuss today including an
affiliate SEO email marketing social
media search engine market they're all
there on our YouTube channel so thank
you again and look forward to seeing you
on future webinars hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here